we got some stuff to figure out cuz we
have sucked we're sitting here at 18 and
22 that's not good I can always raise my
hand and say corporate a reason number
one sit right here in front of you and
so I take that up on myself to try to be
that spark and write it and write the
ship defense is all about want a will I
want to play defense and saying that you
can't just sit back and say well we
contested the shots well and they just
made them you have to make people miss
so we still got to figure that out
everybody does play better against us
that's just the reality that's what
comes with the territory of being a a
dynasty a great team we have to adjust
to that